here we are at CES 2012 with the Nokia
Lumia 900 it's one of two new windows
phones debuting on AT&T this year the
Nokia Lumia 900 is slightly larger than
its sister the Lumia 800 which came out
in 2011 it's got a 4.3 inch AMOLED
screen inside it's got a 1.4 megahertz
Qualcomm processor since everyone loves
taking pictures with their smart phone
the Lumia 900 has an 8-megapixel
rear-facing camera with a Carl Zeiss
lens on the front it's got a 1 megapixel
camera the Lumia 900 looks a lot like
the Lumia 800 it's got a similar form
factor on the side it's got a volume
rocker a power button and a shutter
button for the camera the Lumia 900 runs
Windows Phone mango and it will be out
sometime in the next few months